now yesterday we saw Liz truss sitting
side by side for the first time with her
new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt but what
might their body language tell us about
what they really think of each other who
better to tell us and analyze that than
the psychologist and Body Language
expert Judy James hey Judy it's good to
see you this morning what was your
overarching view of uh the two of them
together yesterday
okay I mean from start to finish the
body language
um was so hard to Fathom I mean I would
imagine that the best way to describe it
would be a a lack of what I would call
emotional intelligence I mean if we look
at the arrival here there'd been an hour
of where's Wally going on at this point
nobody knew where she was she bounced in
she sat down smiling uh you can't see
hunt behind Penny there but she was
chatting to him and laughing which I
filmed very strange I mean Penny have
been standing there like somebody on a
sinking ship for over an hour armed with
a tea cup bailing her out she did three
apologies
um that were delegated to her and then
trust arrived and started laughing and
chatting behind her so there was no
bonding going on between the two women
um with hunt clearly those signals were
supposed to display the idea that oh
look everything's fine we're really
going and on well and this is my new
Chancellor and you know we adore one
another but we've seen those signals
with her previous Chancellor but how
long ago was it I don't know a week
maybe two weeks ago but then um she fell
into what we can see here which is what
I call wax Works mode she didn't join in
at all her facial expression became
Frozen we've got this hands lightly
classed at that and she started to uh a
slightly sickly Frozen smile and if you
watch her eyes there she's doing what
would be called an eye Sutton now that K
can often be referred to when somebody's
got a burst of adrenaline caused by
anger or frustration it can cause that
but I look very closely for a very long
period of time and it didn't seem to
have that aspect to it in fact the
longer I look the more it looked like
somebody who's fighting sleep you know
if you go to say about a player of the
cinema you can feel your eyes beginning
to droop it was that kind of blinking
going on and then the only other sign
that we got from her body language and
I'm sure you've spotted this when you've
interviewed her in the flesh it's what I
would call her poker tell which where
she does a little
blue uh when just when she doesn't like
something her chin sort of moves from
side to side but apart from that very
little endorsement signals going on
normally we'd expect to see her looking
at her nodding agreeing but she just sat
there looking slightly glad to looking
at the opposition but without any real
focus and then obviously after half an
hour she put it off again very strange
yeah do you uh get the impression from
looking at her body language that she's
determined or defeated
I think oh okay I'm on the fence on this
one
um I determined in the brain cells but I
think generally her body's telling her
that she's defeated she's she's
self-heckling I mean we saw when she was
asked if she believed in the party into
the next election it's so really
Dreadful pauses that she makes before
she answers I mean nobody should leap on
or not so that looks as they go along
but that slightly bewildered I haven't
actually thought about this and then
again yesterday we had that strange
laugh before answering so it looks as
though
um she's desperately trying to persuade
us and herself that she's in there and
she's going to hang on but her body
language is heckling her and saying no
actually
um not perhaps quite as confident as I'm
trying to sound yeah uh well we've got
PM cues tomorrow so it'd be interesting
how to get another opportunity to see
how they interact with each other and
I'm sure we'll chat to you again Judy
before thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you